the jurogan experience
i tell i think of the current guys he
probably influenced the most guys out of
new york because if you watch it tell
right now in particular here's that's a
guy that's probably the most
underappreciated
and uh underrated even though i know the
fans rate him very highly i'm talking
about like the general public
every comedy fan that knows david tell
rates him very very highly he might not
be the best comic alive
but
criminally underappreciated as far as
the general public goes and if you see
him he's so good and his jokes are so
sharp and they and you get into that
dave attel rhythm yeah and that's all
you want to hear and then guys start
doing jokes like him he started doing
that he's got this way or talking and
it's so addictive it's so i've seen so
many guys like and i don't they're not
bad guys but you see like a little bit
of a telling them because they're like
insecure and they don't know how to be
funny and they're trying to be funny and
so they try to do it like a towel
you know they have that like very
pronounced sort of accentuation of words
and i remember
insomniac was like big when i was
growing up that was kind of this big
hollywood thing but then i didn't see
much after that i know
wasn't he like an hbo young comedian
special is that partly like him like he
just loves stand-up he'll go on last at
the seller
he kind of just enjoys he does a lot of
like late night sets and he can revive
an audience and he's not like a big
energy guy either it's like he's just
doing it all he's the master of what he
does brilliant jokes but yeah um i think
the the first big success was definitely
insomniac and then through insomniac he
developed a drinking problem and then
through the drinking problem he quit and
then became the best comic alive like it
really happened all through that like
his um his quitting drinking everybody
agrees like unanimously that his act
sharpened up radically it got really
really really good
and i think it's just his mind is free
it's amazing yeah like the amount of new
jokes he's just a machine and he's super
dedicated yeah that's the thing it's
like he has a thing that he's really
good at that he really loves that he's
very dedicated to so he's like always
after it and so because he's always
after it he's always doing all these
sets and he's always sharp
and i mean that's really what it's at
for all of us you know and there's some
there's kind of a almost a monastic
approach that he takes he wears the same
clothes essentially every night
i don't mean like the same clothes but
he doesn't vary in his style just like
the same hat the same you know
look dave just sold out the stand up
live in phoenix and killed it down there
i mean it's not like he's not loved yeah
like the people that know and there's
plenty of them love him
but as far as like
great comics that don't get put into the
category of great comics like he's
number one on my list yeah i love him
too he's great yeah he might be the one
of the best of all time and right now
he's in his prime and i think a lot of
it is like he stopped drinking unlike us
and uh turned his life around
what what is the last special do you
know was that no was it bumping mike's
on netflix
well that's interesting too right him
doing that thing with jeff that's a
really fun thing
because they're both so good off their
feet yeah you know um skanks for the
memories was his first big cd
that was a really good one that he did
at denver the comedy works it's really
fun that's a great club